you're on Netflix and Netflix is
becoming they've got so many shows now
you're getting to know the other Netflix
talent are you guys starting to mingle
how does it work yeah you know I know
this is an anecdote but I'm ready for it
I know that what you want to talk about
is this nothing's been pre-planned is a
recipe yes peach cobbler we are about to
stir it up and so the situation you're
talking about Conan I don't know what
you're talking about I asked a simple
question
do you mix it up with the other people
all the time and so this one this one
was in Brazil and I was ill a nice bit
not like Turner Turner doesn't send us
they don't see Annapolis yeah I prepared
sidebar
yeah these Brazilian kids are crazy for
this word velcro do you know what this
is what I know what velcro is yeah I
think it's like imagine velcro but
sexual what do you know I mean this is a
thing in Brazil now how does no pro
become sexual I don't know but anyway
the kids love velcro they're constantly
sending me messages like do you want a
Velcro you want a moko and they're like
all those laughing face emojis like
right right thing does anybody know how
velcro is a satire but I don't I don't
think I can well the only thing I can
picture is the way you separate velcro
and it kind of fix but like with your
privates
[Laughter]
I'm talking to a sailor I don't have my
75th birthday last week
[Applause]
Netflix this Brazilian Netflix mixer and
it's a me who's oh do buzz Samira Wylie
this is you know we're having a great
time we're there for the Pride Parade
great and there's other characters there
from for the sense8 now the funked sense
a great daredevil the blind right so
that's the main thing the blind show he
has no different powers sight impaired
yeah the whole show about a guy huh and
how about we get to know each other you
know to be talking about like a Netflix
mixer orgy was the suggestion wait who
suggested you guys have an orange I
don't recall
okay I don't think I don't the idea was
that okay you're there at a Netflix
mixer in Brazil and someone says hey
we're all on the same affiliate of the
same company we could get it on together
I dump all the cast together and make a
gumbo yeah it's like the wild wild west
of television do you know that seems
like such I want in on this Netflix
thing at orgies like Annie says we get
saltines in Indianapolis fantastic so
you guys get together then I'm like you
know and maybe it was my suggestion
maybe not nobody knows but I was like
you know you should know caring for a
lady of your age yeah
you can't look my undergarments in
little things that connect fleiger oh so
you're there but you suggested an orgy
who was down with the orgy and who
wasn't down with the orgy I just want to
say pretty much everybody was game and
gotten Tonya this is the best place on
television okay this is yes fantastic
but then you know I think everybody had
to go to their rooms and you know yeah
and orgy quickly becomes a negotiation
scenario they gotta call their
significant other so you know now I'm on
the line on the FaceTime with Freddy
lovely Freddy what's good for anyone who
doesn't know you and and Fred Armisen
are an item
yeah so you had to call Fred Armisen yes
and was he Pro orgy or or against orgy
this is an a.1 winner boyfriend you know
what I mean look this is a really
top-notch guy I love you you know you
will do what you need to do you know
that man know what you need to do like
you know you want to make friends with
the new members of
let's just put up a picture of Fred
getting the phone call there's Fred do
what you got to do you know he's a
genius no no no I love Fred but I don't
I don't think that's the correct
response for when you cry I agree one
thing leads to another now I'm
distracted bits bits bits all of a
sudden it's what 3:00 in the morning
doing it yeah you wanna go go go have
your orgy right and now I'm Mike oh so
now it's like a legal orgy like it's
kind of ruins the grills fun out of it
thrill of the kill yeah yeah when you go
and ask everybody are you down with the
orgy and then papers are signed
it's not an orgy anymore it's basically
like you bought a home agents want 10%
you'd get a noisy you got a timeshare
not good and yes so then I was like
maybe I don't want to have the orgy and
it got better later in the day everybody
had to be up at 5:00 a.m. then it
doesn't have I started talking so good
concern first of all is it cheating to
have an orgy or is cheating something
like Conan you're super hot let's you
know meet up later like that's more like
cheating
yeah but speeding isn't like now we're
talking cheating isn't like hey guys
let's go back to my place and do it yeah
you just you just gestured to 200
no I don't want to get naked in front of
all of them body shakes what if it's
just you and me and it's also friends
point was like that's not even really a
thing that's not like yeah you know
that's more like a crazy slumber party
pickup basketball game yeah listen we I
wish we had more time they're telling me
we're out of time that's weird man
listen listen to me listen to me yeah
listen to me
I'm gonna be better here's listen to me
listen to me yes I want this but last be
the last thing your 85 year old ears
ever hear thank you
you've got to get it yes Andy get Andy
and I in on the Netflix more cakey not
cuz this is coming off
[Applause]
you